des arbres au cœur même des champs de
culture la grosse foresterie un choix
éthique pour Bruno et Jean-Loup meunier
céréalier converti au bio depuis 6 ans
on va avoir deux choses qu'on a les
armes qu'on va mettre en ligne tous les
8 10 12 mètres en fonction des objectifs
qu'on a dans la grande forêt et entre
les armes on a toute une zone qui va
être non cultivée et nous cette zone là
va permettre de faire un réservoir à
biodiversité on va voir notamment si
souvent les cire les carabes les
coccinelles qui sont des prédateurs
naturels des pucerons et qui vont nous
aider à réguler c'est les attaques de
pucerons la grosse foresterie concerne
aujourd'hui 21 des 42 hectares de
l'exploitation ses avantages sont
multiples maintient des sols apports en
eau et en nutriments supports de lutte
contre la sécheresse
au printemps les deux hommes
alternissent les cultures et après
chaque moisson ils utilisent le six pan
pour reposer et enrichir la terre le
CIPAN c'est une culture intermédiaire
entre deux cultures de vente comme là
les prochaines on aura une partie une
parcelle en tournesol là on a eu du blé
donc on met des six pans en place pour
préserver pour éviter l'érosion et nous
en tant que bio c'est pour ramener de
l'azote suivant les plantes les
légumineuses que l'on met
l'agroforesterie permet également de
soutenir la biodiversité plus que des
armes on voit l'intérêt de la bande qui
n'est pas travaillé qui reste sauvage et
qui sert d'habitat pour tout toute la
faune locale auxiliaire avec les mulot
on va voir des rapaces qui vont arriver
donc la repas sont leurs mets des
perchoirs pour qu'ils puissent se poser
et aller chasser les mulots qui sont
dans de bonnes conditions
mais l'engagement environnemental ne
s'arrête pas là l'exploitation comprend
un moulin à eau édifié en l'an 1036 un
support idéal pour produire son
électricité
alors voici une turbine Caplan du nom de
sondage parce que suivant le libido on
peut régler les listes jusqu'à 900
litres ses coudes chaque seconde
permettant de produire 15 kilos watts
elle est installé depuis 2005 par 11 je
fais 20 ans des fois 30 000 des fois
40000 km je fais tout ce qui est
chauffage et tout ce qui est eau chaude
une énergie propre qui sert également au
mobil-home installé pour le camping à la
ferme ajoutez à cela une station
d'épuration bio autonome une vingtaine
de moutons pour l'entretien c'est une
vision globale en faveur de
l'environnement qu'on développait les
biens nommés meuniers père et fils je
veux sur Internet quelqu'un ici parler
de faire une oasis un peu de verdure
comme un point d'un point d'acupuncture
vert pour la planète et on est
exactement là dedans on essaye de faire
mieux et on essaye aussi de travailler
sur l'autonomie et être moins dépendant
du système et avec une vision assez
pessimiste de l'avenir de mon côté et en
me disant que si on peut avoir quelque
chose d'autonome qui tourne tout seul
pour se nourrir se chauffer produire un
peu de bois et ben demain ça sera
peut-être vraiment pas mal
un retour au passé pour mieux affronter
l'avenir